hey guys is Eric Nam and I'm here to do
first times with BuzzFeed nervous I
should preface this by saying I have the
worst memory I feel like I'm just making
stuff up if I go somewhere and you asked
me the same question you're gonna have a
different answer so don't hold me to
this I'm just putting it out there into
the universe it's not that I'm a liar
it's just I have no recollection all
right here we go
first time meeting a celebrity I think
it might have been Ciara and I met her
at a taco joint in Atlanta I was in high
school when his after soccer I went to
the to taco spot to get a burrito and
Sierra was there and she was beautiful
and I asked her for a photo and she took
a photo with me and I was very very very
happy about he's here
I was really should next all right first
concert you ever attended was a concert
that I don't even remember the name of
my band is that sad so what I consider
my personal real first concert is John
Legend in high school with Robin Thicke
as an opener and it was amazing it was
it was amazing y'all watching this I'm a
fan first time you became a meme well my
entire existence is pretty much a meme I
used to be MC of the show pretty much
they wanted me and my co-host to act
insane super high energy screamed things
constantly do crazy dances we're in
credible costumes and that really built
a great stockpile of just weapons that
people can use against because means I
appreciate it all you guys you know I
don't
Malaya all right next up first thing you
do when you wake up I snooze my alarm
like ten times it happened this morning
my first alarm was set for like 9:30 I
got out of bed at 10:20 so for every
eight minutes over and over and over and
over again I don't know why I do that to
myself because if I could just get up at
one time I should just set one alarm and
I don't have to listen to this a fire
ant plant but my body doesn't function
that way first TV appearance the
audition program that I did in Korea to
make me into a singer that got me here
with you guys at BuzzFeed I remember I
was so nervous I was like shaking
onstage and it this is in Korea but I
barely spoke Korean so they would be
telling me to do things and I had no
idea what they're saying it's got much
better now you guys I can survive in
Korea I do a lot more in Korea now but
first impressions mean a lot mine is not
the best first time in front of a crowd
singing was the high school talent show
and it was me and a bunch dudes we made
a medley I think it had in sync had
Backstreet Boys I think we did that and
we had like a horribly choreographed
routine but you know what everybody
loved it my first cell phone I think I
got in seventh grade I think it was a
Samsung flip phone young people probably
have no idea what that looks like they
did exist at some point my dad got one
and I got one and my dad got the one
that had color on it and I got the black
and white people probably think I'm like
it antique right now I'm talking about
this so I had a flip phone it's black
and white
it only had buttons had like one game
with a line that loops looks like a poop
that's like trying to grow and you just
keep going around like a caterpillar and
that was literally all you could do that
was the first celebrity crush I think it
was Jennifer Aniston
like Jennifer Aniston it's like you
watch friends you're like she's so hot
and like relatable first red carpet
experience for the audition show that
they feel like the last the last episode
the finale they had a big red carpet
thing with the ton of press but I look I
don't want to talk about it man it's
embarrassing when I'm on this show I
don't have a say over like how I'm
styled or how my hair makeup or done and
for some reason they insisted on making
me the kid that stood out I show up like
you're wearing this today and I was like
hell no I'm not wearing that it was a
leather jacket with like studs all over
it
from what I remember and it had feathers
like big-ass feathers stuff that people
used to use as like pens in like the
1600s it's like the Iron Throne on a
jacket it was just oh that's what I wore
that's why now I wear the most
outrageous clothes look at this this is
quite scandalous thanks for having me
hope you guys check out my music and
I'll see you guys again very soon
[Music]